und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber büttenabend es
hat keinen sinn mehr beim corona treffen
von bundes- und landesregierungen morgen
lockerungen zu erwarten
das gibt die lage nicht her bürger
wissenschaft und politik sind inzwischen
recht klug geworden was die beurteilung
der lage angeht deutschland hat es im
frühjahr mit großen opfern schon mal
geschafft die kurve zu brechen
heute sind die zahlen leider bedeutend
höher als die dynamik damals nach
praktisch zwei wochen neuer
einschränkungen ist der vormarsch der
pandemie noch nicht gestoppt immer noch
kommen täglich im sieben tage schnitt
fast 19.000 neue infektionen dazu
immerhin der zuwachs beschleunigt sich
nicht mehr die kurve wird flach es muss
aber nach unten gehen
das frühjahr hat gezeigt dafür braucht
es ausdauer
nachdem shutdown damals ging die kurve
noch rund elf tage nach oben
und als der trend gebrochen war ging es
dann aber wieder steil nach unten
in einer milden pandemie in einem sommer
der manchen dazu brachte das virus
leichter zu nehmen als es offenbar ist
morgen werden die bundesregierung und
ministerpräsidenten entscheiden wie es
weitergehen soll
in einer auch politisch heiklen lage
daniel ponce beschreibt wie die aussieht
kommunikativ gab es in den letzten
wochen eine erstaunliche wende dieses
anfangs der teilstaat dauern werde hart
so aber dafür kurz änderte sich die
tonlage bald obwohl sich die maßnahmen
noch gar nicht niederschlagen konnten
völlig klar man kann nicht am ersten
dezember nochmal einfach weitermachen
als gäbe es kein corona denn die zahlen
die wir jetzt haben reichen bei weitem
nicht aus wir haben maximal eine leichte
seitwärtsbewegung erreicht die kanzlerin
verweigerte der gastronomie diese woche
dann die zusage im dezember wieder
öffnen zu dürfen und wählte einen
drastischen vergleich wie das auch bei
der spanischen grippe der fall war muss
man jetzt davon ausgehen dass die zweite
welle welle härter ist erneut düstere
rhetorik je länger die krise dauere
desto weniger würden bedrohungsszenarien
verfangen sollte medizin soziologie
holger pfaff und seine jahrelange
forschung auf diesem gebiet ergab zudem
dass anordnung in einer krise
prinzipiell nur bedingt wirksam sind
die bevölkert gewissermaßen als maschine
gesehen die auf anordnungen folge
leistet das funktioniert nur zum teil
weil das explizit die soziale kontrolle
erfordert besser wäre es die leute
würden aus innerer überzeugung handeln
eingriffe des systems in die lebenswelt
die privaten meisten scheitern
verurteilt eigenverantwortung statt
staatlicher eingriffe ins tief
persönliche die überwältigende mehrheit
scheint dazu in der lage
doch was wenn eigenverantwortung nicht
gelebt sondern demonstrativ verweigert
wird
hierzu ist auch medial eine scharfe
debatte entbrannt in den acht corona
monaten sei eine untergesetzliche
parallel rechtsordnung entstanden sagt
verfassungsrechts experte heribert
prantl
das hat ungute auswirkungen zu diesen
auswirkungen gehören auch die zum teil
völlig irrationalen proteste gegen die
staatliche pandemie bekämpfung ein
abwägen jeder maßnahme im parlament vor
der entscheidung fordert die opposition
union und spd hatten viel angekündigt
durchpeitschen wollen sie nun ein neues
infektionsschutzgesetz dass im gegenteil
die exekutive dauerhaft viel spielraum
lassen könnte
wenn allerdings in einem solchen gesetz
nur anschließen maßnahmen abgenickt
werden die vorher von der
bundesregierung eingeführt werden dann
läuft diese parlamentsbeteiligung ins
leere geht auch nicht ein land über und
podcast zu reagieren und diese mpk runde
wie man so schön sagt das hat ja
monarchische züge wo man der hofstaat
zusammenkommt und danach wird verkündet
was ist es scheint aber grundmuster zu
bleiben zeigt sich vor dem treffen
morgen womöglich samt verschärfung wir
merkten dass noch immer im privaten
bereich das infektionsgeschehen sehr
stark anzieht und deshalb glaube ich
dass man auch über die frage wie wir den
kontakt beschränkungen ausgestaltet
haben noch mal reden dass wir darüber
reden müssen
zehn personen sind schon relativ viel
unterdessen stellt sich mit zunehmender
dauer umso lauter die frage wie lange
eine parlamentarische demokratie sich
das leisten will einen exklusiv
exekutiven entscheider kreis der nach
eigenem ermessen tief in grundrechte
eingreifen
bei solchen eingriffen beruft sich die
politik sehr gerne auf die wissenschaft
der das aber nicht immer recht sein kann
am helmholtz-zentrum für
infektionsforschung in braunschweig
arbeiten hunderte biologen statistiker
und fachmediziner für viren und
epidemien zusammen
an genau diesen themen unter ihnen die
virologin professor melanie bringt man
sie lehrte und forschte in den usa und
an mehreren deutschen universitäten wir
erreichen sie an ihrem institut guten
namen professor drink bringt man die
jetzigen maßnahmen wurden ja als
wellenbrecher bezeichnet die zweite
welle der infektion sollte davon
zerstört werden was sagen ihnen die
zahlen läuft dass die zahlen sehen
eigentlich genau so aus wie man sich das
vorgestellt hat wir hatten noch eine
woche lang steigende zahlen denn die
infektion die wir in der statistik sehen
sind ja vor einer woche schon geschehen
und jetzt sehen wir eine stabilisierung
das ist genau das was wir uns erhofft
haben geht es dann endlich auch habe
unten wo bewähren sich diese kurve hin
genau das ist die große frage
denn wir wollen ja wir wollen ja nicht
dass sich die zahlen jetzt auch
dem hohen niveau einpendeln wir wollen
dass sie sinken und da kommt es jetzt
darauf an wie wir uns in den kommenden
zwei drei wochen verhalten das
individuelle verhalten ist jetzt ganz
entscheidend und zwar kontakte zu
reduzieren wo auch immer es möglich ist
die politik nimmt sich ja genau das
jetzt vor die wollen sich morgen treffen
um zu gucken wie sie das hinkriegen für
die politik ist es ja so die in einem
freiheitlichen staat kann die politik
nicht regeln was menschen hinter ihrer
haustür tun oder nur sehr sehr schwer
sie kann aber relativ einfach regeln was
in konzertsälen den restaurants in
theatern und auf der straße passiert was
sagt der virologe und was sagte pardo
virologin was die richtige maßnahme
eigentlich wäre das im öffentlichen raum
oder geht es mehr um das was hinter den
haustüren passieren also ich glaube eine
ganz entscheidende frage ist jetzt wie
wir strategisch aus dieser ganzen
geschichte heraus kommen aus dieser
welle und da muss die politik jetzt
klare ziele auch ausarbeiten wo wollen
wir eigentlich genau hin denn ich glaube
die menschen muss man ja mitnehmen bei
diesen entscheid und hoffe ich einen
vorschlag in hannover hin wollen wenn
man wenn wir zum beispiel in die tage
des sommers zu reagieren wollten genau
genau denn das wäre eine gute strategie
dass man die zahlen jetzt so weit runter
drückt wie's geht dass die
gesundheitsämter mit der kontakt nach
verfolgung wieder hinterher kommen man
kann ja auch mal ins ausland schauen in
länder die es ganz gut im griff haben
diese pandemie die zahlen sehr niedrig
halten und in denen sieht man ja auch
sehr gut dass sie wirtschaftlich wieder
sehr gut funktionieren und da lohnt sich
glaube ich sehr ein blick ins ausland
ich sage nicht dass man es genauso
machen muss wie dort aber die machen ja
schon etwas besser und da kann man sich
glaube ich ein paar strategien ab
schauen welche strategie würde man sich
zb abschauen wenn man sagt es geht auch
um die schulen für die deutsche politik
ist es ja ganz wichtig die schulen offen
zu halten das hat man ihm früher gesehen
wie übel es ankommt wenn kitas und
schulen geschlossen werden
nun sind sie werden sie offen gehalten
das heißt das was man dort ab bremsen
würde
muss man jetzt in anderen bereichen
abbremsen um irgendwie wieder auf
niedrigere zahlen zu kommen
ja ich glaube das ziel muss sein
wirklich in allen bereichen wo es
möglich ist kontakte zu reduzieren und
das infektionsgeschehen zu reduzieren
zumindest dh die masten pflicht in den
schulen wird uns sehr helfen wir werden
dadurch eine reduktion sehen was aber
auch natürlich wichtig ist es dass wir
klassengrößen eventuell auch reduzieren
vor allem eventuell auch in der also vor
allem in der älteren schüler gruppe ja
die oberstufe zum beispiel da ist es
denke ich sinnvoll auch teilweise das
lernen nach hause zu verlegen also ein
hybrides konzept zu entwickeln das wäre
glaube ich etwas was kein richtig wehtut
aber was das infektionsgeschehen ganz
gut kontrollieren könnte jetzt aloha was
natürlich erweiterung wichtig ist dass
wir auch im privaten bereich immer noch
darauf achten niemanden zu infizieren
ist glaube ich wirklich am einfachsten
sich vorzustellen einer in dieser
begegnung ist gerade infiziert und wir
sollten uns so verhalten dass wir uns
nicht anstecken beziehungsweise dass wir
niemanden anstecken
und da ist das masken tragen tatsächlich
ein wichtiger faktor und das ist auch
genau das was in der gastronomie ein
problem darstellt denn da sitzt man ja
dann doch über längere zeit zusammen hat
keine maske auf unterhält sich und da
kommt es natürlich auch zu infektionen
der rat der biologin und ich bitte sie
und die zuschauer um vergebung dafür
dass durch die verzögerung zwischen uns
beiden man sich immer mal wieder
gegenseitig ins wort fällt herzlichen
dank
ein vergleich aus deutschlands
nachbarschaft nun vor wenigen wochen war
belgien in einer viel schlimmeren lage
als deutschland heute und jetzt kann
gunnar krüger berichten sie schaffen es
den trend zu brechen offenbar im
allerletzten augenblick in la novia
beginnt die nachtschicht wie so oft in
dieser woche nachdem wir diese person
aufgenommen haben bleibt uns ein freies
bett
ich komme gerade zurück von den
stationen da liegen vier schwache
patienten die eigentliche her gehöre
sondergericht belgien auf dem
scheitelpunkt der zweiten welle
wegen der nachrücker bleiben
intensivbetten knapp bleibt die angst
vor überlastung
ich möchte den leuten dann sagen dass
ich ihnen nicht helfen kann sind die
wissen das ist schwer
die zweite welle kennt zwei welten im
krankenhaus dem krisenzentrum manche
kurven fallen die neuinfektionen die
neuaufnahmen andere bleiben hoch die der
intensivpatienten und die der toten ohne
wachsamkeit hat wohl zu schnell
nachgelassen
wir waren zu zuversicht dass wir und die
bevölkerung wir haben gelernt dass wir
die regeln erst lockern können wenn die
fälle seien noch deutlich weiter sinken
diesmal sind wir vorsichtige diesmal
warten wir lenken restaurants sind seit
einem monat viele läden seit zwei wochen
zu noch mal vier wochen lang gilt nun
wenig kontakt nachts ausgangssperre und
ein bußgeld für versuche das zu umgehen
anrufe bei marie simon will in lüttich
auch ein hotspot der teil locker und
wirke aber mit quälender verzögerung das
erklärt weshalb wir dann auch nur die
langsame verbissen sind sie auch sehr
vorsichtig uns sagen nicht jetzt alles
vorbei die zweite welle ist vorbei auch
bei ihr bilder die einsicht schaffen für
regeln die ihrer meinung nach zu spät
kamen
man hat es oft genug gesagt aber die die
leute wollten es nicht hören
es ist schwierig das auch zu nehmen was
man nicht gerne hören was einen aufstand
in seiner eigenen freiheit das ende der
nacht in la lluvia ein patient wird
entlassen
ich bin ein anderer mensch als wäre ich
von den toten auferstanden aus seiner
anlage wurden sie sind gladiatoren kein
quatsch ich weiß was ich erlebe in
belgien musste es erst so weit kommen
bevor es langsam wieder besser wird
wenn so ein bericht ein positiver ist
der hoffnung macht merkt man wie ernst
die lage ist
nachrichten von gundula gans am heutigen
volkstrauertag hat der britische
thronfolger prinz charles im bundestag
gesprochen
75 jahre nach ende des zweiten
weltkrieges würdigte er dabei die
partnerschaft von großbritannien und
deutschland gemeinsam mit
bundespräsident steinmeier gedachte er
in der neuen wache aller kriegsopfer im
bundestag warnte prinz charles zu
versöhnung und rief dazu auf angesichts
aller krisen gemeinsam für das gute
einzutreten
abwechselnd auf englisch und deutsch
sprach er auch die zeit nach dem wechsel
an
wir werden immer freunde partner und
verbündete zu sein
in belarus hauptstadt minsk sind
vermummte sicherheitskräfte erneut
massiv gegen friedliche demonstranten
vorgegangen
nach angaben von menschenrechtlern
wurden allein heute mehr als 900
menschen festgenommen darunter auch
wieder journalisten den protesten gegen
machthaber lukaschenko hatten sich
wieder tausende angeschlossen
wie an jedem sonntag seit der
präsidentenwahl am 9 august
lukaschenko hatte sich trotz
internationaler zweifel am wahlergebnis
zum sieger erklärt die eu erkennt ihn
als präsidenten nicht mehr an
nach dem ende der kämpfe in bergkarabach
im südkaukasus bekommt armenien zehn
tage mehr zeit für den abzug seiner
truppen dem waffenstillstandsabkommen
zufolge hätte das land heute ein erstes
umkämpftes gebiet an aserbaidschan ab
treten sollen
viele armenier haben ihre wohnorte
bereits verlassen einige brannten ihre
häuser nieder
russische truppen sollen die vereinbarte
waffenruhe überwachen aserbaidschan
sagte den schutz christlicher kirchen
und klöster in der konfliktregion zu
mitten im handelskrieg mit den usa hat
china mit 14 wirtschaftsnationen der
asien-pazifik-region das größte
freihandelsabkommen der welt
abgeschlossen nach acht jahre langen
verhandlungen wurde es auf einem
virtuellen gipfel unterzeichnet 2,2
milliarden menschen leben in diesem
wirtschaftsraum der knapp ein drittel
des weltweiten handelsvolumens umfasst
das abkommen verringert zölle und
definiert einheitliche regeln um
lieferketten zu erleichtern
mit der freihandelszone will die region
wirtschaftlich stärker als die eu werden
mittlerweile steht er nun fest dass der
demokrat joe biden der präsident elect
der gewählte präsident ist das machte
aus donald trump einen präsident feiert
wenn man sich auf seine sprache ebene
begibt das ergebnis will er nicht
akzeptieren twitterte heute nachmittag
beiden haben nur in den fake news medien
gewonnen er trump werde gar nichts zu
gestehen
bei dem tweet blieben ihm noch 160
zeichen da hätte er konkrete hinweise
auf betrug anbringen können konnte er
wohl nicht formal muss er beides wahl
nicht anerkennen
kein gesetz verlangt dass es ist nur
seit jahrhunderten brauch und wichtig
für die seele der nation amerikanische
wahlkämpfe sind so viel länger teurer
brutaler als jeder wahlkampf in
deutschland anderthalb jahre lang
zerfleischen sich die kandidaten und die
apparate der parteien erst gegen die
konkurrenten im eigenen lager und dann
mit allen verbliebenen kräften
gegeneinander
da werden tiefe gräben gerissen diesmal
besonders tief nach so etwas ist die
ausgestreckte hand des verlierers eine
elegante rede über neu anfangen und
gemeinsamkeiten nicht bloß guter stil
sondern medizin für die demokratie
lebenswichtig trump verweigert sie warum
war unsere frage an dritter jäger in
madame tussaud haben sie donald trump
schon in den politischen ruhestand
geschickt raus aus dem präsidialen anzug
die wachsfigur trägt jetzt golf club
weniger amtsgeschäfte mehr golf spielen
scheint seit tagen tatsächlich chance
motto auch heute steht er wieder auf dem
rasen nachdem er zuvor für mediale
aufregung sorgte beiden habe gewonnen
gab er zum ersten mal auf twitter zu
aber nur weil die wahl manipuliert
worden sei eines ist dem präsidenten
bereits jetzt gelungen er hat den
glauben an die legitimität
demokratischer wahlen zerstört zumindest
bei seinen anhängern von denen
zehntausende am samstag in der
hauptstadt protestierten
wenn du dein vertrauen verlierst hast du
keine nation mehr
dann kann man auch keiner weiteren wahl
trauen das geht doch nicht
trump arbeitet an der legende des
betrogenen siegers und daran seinem
nachfolger joe biden und ganz amerika
das leben schwerzumachen rausschmiss des
verteidigungsministers aus dem pentagon
im sensiblen prozess der machtübergabe
eine gefährdung der nationalen
sicherheit meinen experten
ich denke dass der präsident noch um mit
seinen worten zu sprechen unerledigte
geschäfte hat und er will nicht dass die
in der bürokratie des pentagons beerdigt
werden
er hat nun leute rein gebracht die in
jeder situation loyal sind und die alles
tun werden um sicher zu gehen dass
trumps anordnungen in den nächsten 60
tagen erfüllt werden
unerledigtes erledigen ein ad hoc
truppenabzug aus afghanistan bis
jahresende wäre da denkbar
außerdem will trump laut medienberichten
wohl weitere sanktionen gegen iran
verhängen
das würde beiden die rückkehr zum atom
deal erschweren
möglich auch dass trump die bundes
behörden weiter ausdünnt und versucht
sich selbst zu begnadigen um künftiger
strafverfolgung zu entgehen
am wildesten aber spekuliert wird ob
trump sich über den wählerwillen
hinwegsetzen würde sollten seine
gerichtlichen klagen gegen das
wahlergebnis nicht bis zum 8 dezember
vom tisch sein könnten republikanisch
geführte bundesstaaten eigene wahlleute
bestimmen
trotz eines beiden sieges
unwahrscheinlich bei einem
unberechenbaren trump aber denkbar
donald trump ist so unvorhersehbar hat
so viele normen so viele rechtliche
vorgaben in den vereinigten staaten
achtet dass es im moment total unklar
ist wie weit er gehen und eine wirklich
gefährliche situation schaffen wird
welche regierung ist künftig am zug die
zeit wird es wohl zeigen so trump am
freitag bis zum 20 januar hat er noch
das sagen mit allen präsidialen
befugnissen damit zu disziplinen in
denen die gegner sofort der brite lewis
hamilton ist zum siebten mal formel 1
weltmeister mit seinem sieg beim großen
preis der türkei kann hamilton in der
wm-wertung nicht mehr eingeholt werden
sportlich steht der mercedes pilot nun
auf einer stufe mit rekordchampion
michael schumacher
katja stresow über einen emotionalen
sieg kurz nachdem lewis hamilton die
ziellinie überquert hatte wurde es
emotional für alle kinder da draußen die
vom unmöglichen träumen
ihr könnt es schaffen sagte ein
sichtlich gerührter hamilton über sein
funk gemeint damit sicher mehr als die
tatsache dass er heute seinen zehnten
saisonsieg holte an einem tag der
eigentlich nicht dafür gemacht schien
hamilton startet ungewohnt nur von
position sechs aus ins rennen doch der
regen in istanbul sorgt schon früh für
ein ordentliches durcheinander und
spülte rekordsieger immer weiter nach
vorn knapp 20 runden vor schluss setzte
sich damit an die spitze fährt zu seinem
insgesamt 94 stomp riesig und zum
siebten wm-titel so viele wie michael
schumacher sebastian vettel heute
erstmals in der saison auf dem treppchen
wird hinter sergio perez dritter der
größte ist aber lewis hamilton an diesem
besonderen tag in istanbul
us-golfstar das den johnson hat das
traditionsreiche major turnier in
augusta gewonnen
mit einem rekordergebnis von insgesamt
286 fahren 68 schlägen klar vor einem
debütanten aus südkorea im super und
cameron smith aus australien die jeweils
273 schläge brauchte
der 36 jährige johnson hatte erst vor
einem monat eine krone infektion und nun
noch dies bei den protesten gegen den
ausbau der a 49 in hessen und gegen die
damit verbundenen baum rodungen ist eine
demonstrantin verletzt worden
die frau fiel nach angaben der polizei
aus mehr als drei metern höhe in die
tiefe
die polizei widersprach angaben von
rothens gegnern wonach einsatzkräfte ein
sicherungsseil durchtrennt haben sollen
im dannen röder forst werden auf einer
fläche von 27 hektar bäume für den
weiterbau der autobahn a 49 gefällt die
demonstranten fordern einen sofortigen
stopp der arbeiten mein schatz was ist
das eigentlich ein schatz die frage
stellt und beantwortet eine zauberhafte
ausstellung in einer ganz besonderen
schatzkammer dem weltkulturerbe
völklinger hütte in diesem industriebau
wird es mit diesem thema nicht nur
prachtvoll sondern auch sehr intim und
privat und das sind dann für susanne
freitag die größten schätze millionen
menschen haben jeden samstag auf genau
dieses gerät geguckt es hat millionen
die lottoziehung maschine wurde in
saarbrücken gebracht
gleich daneben der größte mini europas
der saarländische goldenstein 3d druck
in originalgröße ralf beil war starb
klar doch zum zweiten mal hat corona die
eröffnung verhindert dabei ist die
völklinger hütte zu einer großen
schatzkammer geworden der kern der
ausstellung mond ressort das sagt schon
der titel
da geht es eben darum was ist eigentlich
ein schatz was ist wann wirklich
bedeutend was ist uns wichtig
[Musik]
da sitzt er nun allein im bierdeckel
raum in dem die arbeiter früher ihr
pausenbrot aus entdeckt haben sie ihn
auf dem hüttengelände in den 1960 er
jahren war das ein wertvoller bord
zwischen den maschinen ein mix von
stilen und epochen
ja alte keramik kunst aus saargemünd in
lothringen dort die original entwürfe
von gerhard richters berühmte abtei
fenster
[Musik]
glas gold alltagsgegenstände oder in
einem fürstengrab der merowingerzeit
fünf geköpfte pferde ein schatz ist eben
relativ
[Musik]
das ist ein großer bedeutung der fürst
offenbar gewesen sonst hätte man ihm
nicht fünf pferde und zwei runde mit ins
grab gegeben aber es war eben sein grab
und wir sehen es jetzt als kulturgut was
hingekommen ist aber dass es immer ein
mensch der dahintersteht
ein koffer voller feldpostbriefe das ist
das wertvollste für eva maria scherer
immer wieder schrieb ihr vater vom krieg
und wie sehr er sie und ihre mutter
liegt
er starb an der front als sie fünf
monate alt war
sie kennt die nur über seine briefe
[Musik]
für ihre eisenbahnanlage haben sie sogar
original hochofen dreck verarbeitet uwe
braun und seine kollegen arbeiten auf
der dillinger hütte die ist noch im
betrieb und sie haben sie nachgebaut das
modell steht jetzt in weltkulturerbe wir
arbeiten wirklich sehr lange schon mit
herzblut daran und die anlage ist auch
einzig in ihrer art sie ist die größte
transportable modelleisenbahnen mit
industrie charakter also weltweit und
das ist schon in unser schatz
wann eröffnet wird bestimmen infektions
kurven und chor ohne regeln
geduld wird belohnt mit schätzen wie
diesen so zauberhaft wie die ganze
ausstellung und schon offen ist die idee
dass jeder mann jede frau ein bild von
ihrem ganz persönlichen schatz auf die
webseite der ausstellung mord tresor
punkt org hochladen kann
da entsteht gerade eine wunderbare
sammlung christian von rechenberg nun
mit einem ausblick auf wichtiges nächste
woche
[Musik]
am mittwoch wollen bundestag und
bundesrat das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz auf den weg
bringen es wird einen rahmen für
künftige impfprogramme vorgeben
noch wichtiger es soll regeln wie
intensiv und wie lange der staat im
kampf gegen eine pandemie in die
freiheiten der bürger eingreifen darf
das tat die regierung bisher durch
verordnung dafür gab es heftige kritik
nun also eingesetzt dazu man wird es
genau unter die lupe nehmen
am freitag betreten die grünen ein
weiteres stück neuland in klein hatten
sie es schon probiert nun wollen sie
einen ganzen bundesparteitag online
halten nur die parteispitze wird im
berliner tempodrom sitzen hunderte
delegierte sind zugeschaltet drei tage
feilen am neuen grundsatzprogramm
fraglich welche akzente die partei mit
blick auf mögliche koalitionspartner
setzt und welche wunden nach der rodung
des tandem brüder force bleiben die ja
auch die grünen in hessen durchgesetzt
haben
am gleichen tag ein gedenken vor 75
jahren begannen in nürnberg die prozesse
gegen vertreter des ns regimes den saal
600 verließen nach einem jahr
verhandlung nur drei angeklagte als
freie menschen die anderen verurteilten
die richter zu haft- oder zum tode
einer der chef ankläger damals barron's
heute 100 jahre alt wird auf dem festakt
in nürnberg ein grußwort sprechen per
video und das novemberwetter in dieser
neuen woche bleibt herbstlich und
erstmal überwiegend trübe morgen ist es
meist stark bewölkt im norden gibt es
immer wieder schauer
auch an den alpen regen der zum
nachmittag nachlässt höchstwerte 8 bis
13 grad am dienstag regnet es im norden
in den folgenden tagen bleibt es meist
trocken im süden dagegen viel sonne bis
zu 16 grad
wir wünschen einen guten start in die
woche und sehen uns morgen bist dann ist
schillernd
[Musik]